yeah one thing i've always wondered is
that you know the one of the difference
is that
you guys definitely had a point where
you kind of blew up with
your youtube and everything which was
like kind of unprecedented
in our community what was that like
because i've always had this gradual
growth where i've never
had a point when you know i suddenly
just woke up one day and woke up
and a month later i gained 100k subs or
something like that right i think
you guys at one point got like 250 000
subs in one month
and i think that's the most it i think
uh hers was bigger i think yeah the max
i ever got was like 150 200k in a month
yeah then you all started collabing yeah
and then i think your biggest one was
almost like 400k in a month right
yeah you had like 100k in a week yeah i
uh
ridiculous i remember that too like as i
think i said it earlier in the podcast
that like when i called you
i wanted to throw up because like i
don't know it's like
i i knew i wanted to do youtube but then
once like you see that number going up i
suddenly felt like someone pushed me in
the middle of the stage and said dance
like and then all of a sudden there was
just like this huge amount of pressure
over a video that i didn't even really
take that seriously
and then because i remember like you
vocalized
because i remember you made like a video
which is like you know those
good old like obligatory like thank you
for 100 000 subscribers
and then literally a week later i made
it you made two thank you for 200 000
subscribers i did do it 200k and then
like
i think a week later i was like should i
do the 300k i'll just say it in passing
uh in the video so yeah no that was
really crazy um
and i can i still can't believe that
that happened like over
six years ago but i mean maybe i wasn't
really part of the anime community it's
tough to really
feel what that must have felt like
especially for you like where you've
been in it
like really heavily invested i was an
amv which is like a tier of its own so i
wasn't really
i watched uh like a lot of like your
older stuff um on that old account but
um girl 101 maybe
i don't know maybe i commented on one of
those old videos but um
other than that like i was just more
focused of like what i was supposed to
do
and like that by that point joey and i
had already like
made a decision that we weren't going to
work out so we i was just very much on
my own thing and
he was doing his own thing um but yeah
yeah because you've kind of like
transitioned you i've like talked to you
like more recently
you've definitely tried to transition
away from just doing anime content
like was there anything that pushed you
to do that or was it just like your
interest kind of diverged a bit
uh no i think it's just because like
everything i go
everything i do now is stuff that i'm
just honestly genuinely interested in
and like i said before
like anime just puts japanese culture in
front of you and that's why i called
myself an otaku channel just because
like i'm not here to really give
an analysis on an anime there's so many
other youtubers that i think can do the
job better than me
i mean even even though you technically
started in that field though yeah
i know yeah everything you didn't know
about was technically an announcement
yeah yeah um
but like i mean i didn't go doing that
series to think like
like oh i'm this is going to surpass
everyone i just did it because it was
fun to do at the time but
yeah i don't know um totally forgot what
you had just asked
it's kind of funny that basically every
anime youtuber we know now is
trying to do their best to move away
from anime content okay yeah now i
remember uh
yeah so i don't know i think it's just
also it comes with being a personality
i have that privilege that i can you
know
explore and i know that everyone's going
to be okay with it as long as i'm in it
and so i just do stuff i genuinely like
to do
um unlike when it was anime i felt like
there was a lot of pressure
that i have to talk about a specific
anime and then like have to talk about
like what's hot right now
what has what is something i can say
that no one else has said when you're
just personality and the world's your
oyster things are a lot more easier for
you
yeah i think anyone who gets like boxed
into any type of content
eventually feels like oh i want to do
something else but my audience yeah yeah
it's literally me i think
i think every single youtuber like goes
through that one
but every single youtuber was definitely
thought about doing other content
and it's either you know makes a second
channel to do that content changes
yeah i guess like i almost was on that
path of like
kind of big almost becoming a top 10 top
10 channel
with everything you didn't know about
series and i was like oh huge thing back
then yeah it was a huge thing but i was
like i don't want to keep doing this so
i like slowly
like i just thought it was just natural
to just show my face and the face that i
decided to put myself in
was the vocaloid one which i think also
helped perpetuate
um my subscriber count at that point
because now you could see who i was who
was the person that was talking
about this [ __ ] yeah so then through
that people wanted to know me so then i
started
i still did vocaloid but in between i
had fillers of who i was and then
eventually
i gradually got rid of the vocaloid
stuff and just wanted to do my own stuff
and now that i'm in japan
i was like what anime fan doesn't want
to go to japan and what anime fan
doesn't want to go to like
you know uh different types of cafes so
i was like i'mma just do
just that because i know that my
audience wants to do this stuff and i
feel like i'm kind of like there
what is it not gateway in i've i'm i'm
like introduction
yeah introduction they're living
vicariously through through me i guess
through this content and
yeah i don't know that's just the way i
don't know i get that because like
especially one thing that makes me
uncomfortable um
with my own content is when people kind
of see us
as like say ambassadors of anime where
like
i'm just a guy who just has an opinion
what did geeks lost call us again the
heroes of anime makes me uncomfortable
when people are like taking my opinion
really really seriously when i say like
your word is gospel yeah like i like x
or like what and people are just like
yo giggup said it he ruined this
community or something and it's just
like dude it's just i
i i i know as much as i'm just meaning i
know as much as anyone else
it really says something when like the
audience takes your opinion more
seriously then you take your own opinion
yeah exactly and i feel that way with
just not my
you know my content but the trash taste
as well when people some people take
what we sell on trash taste very
seriously you know sometimes we do talk
about serious topics but
when it's just something about anime or
something i'm just like come on dude
it's like yeah